♪ ♪
ERIN: We love working
with all kinds of animals,
but every once in a while,
something comes along
that gets everybody
really excited.
We got llamas coming today.
Like, this is like
a jackpot day.
Hey, how are you?
BRIAN: Doing good. Hi, Ben.
ERIN: Good to see you.
BEN: Hey, how are you?
BRIAN: I'm doing great.
BEN: Llamas are rare
in Nebraska,
and today we have three llamas
coming in all at once.
ERIN: So, this is your herd?
BRIAN: So far.
LORI: So far.
ERIN: So far.
LORI: Brian's wife and I
have been lifelong friends,
and while at the Nebraska
State Fair last year
we decided, "Hey, let's kind of
have a mid-life crisis
and buy some llamas."
ERIN: I can't wait
to meet your babies.
BRIAN: I went to the state fair
and there are these llamas,
and they drew me in
and hypnotized me,
and I knew that was it.
I just had to have a llama.
That's Temptress.
ERIN: Hi, pretty girl.
BEN: We used to call you
temptress in college, didn't we?
ERIN: Oh, shut up.
You did not. That's--
LORI: There's Golden Boy.
ERIN: Hi.
BRIAN: And that's Thunder.
BEN: You are cool.
ERIN: So our lovely lady llama
was bred earlier this year,
and she's here today
to see if she's pregnant.
The llamas on parade.
But first, a round of vaccines
and dewormer for the whole crew.
BEN: Okay, guys, ready?
I'm going to pinch a little bit.
BRIAN: Good boy.
BEN: Okay, good.
BRIAN: Alright.
BEN: Alright, now, we'll
give him his dewormer.
I'm glad he threw
all three llamas in
because they're pack animals,
they like the comfort
of each other.
Good, alright.
One down.
BRIAN: Okay, ready boy?
BEN: Ready, guys?
BRIAN: Hold on, boy, hold on.
ERIN: Llamas are kind of
wiggly to hang on to.
BRIAN: Hold on.
Didn't like that, did you?
Nope.
And she by far is the most
sensitive to being handled.
BEN: Oh, great.
ERIN: Do you want to just
try her in the stall, Ben?
BEN: Yeah. She has
more manpower than we do.
So, we're going to put her
in a safe place
and get her done safely.
ERIN: She's going
to the padded room.
BRIAN: Easy, girl.
BEN: I'm in.
ERIN: Good girl.
BRIAN: Easy, girl.
Whoa, baby, good girl.
BEN: Hold it.
BRIAN: Hold on.
BEN: Good.
BRIAN: Ah, the rodeo. Whoa.
BEN: Got those
big, old long necks.
ERIN: Their necks,
it's like waa, waa, waa!
I think I wanna get ya.
Then I'm gonna spit on ya.
Then when you're not looking
and you're moving away from my
spit, I'm going to kick ya.
BRIAN: Yeah, they're
very powerful for their size,
that's for sure.
BEN: She could bite.
BRIAN: Easy, girl.
Did you get her?
(gurgles)
Oh, boy, that don't sound good.
ERIN: Oh!
BRIAN: There you go.
ERIN: Are you okay?
MONTE: Yeah.
BEN: We're going to give her
a little more.
She spit half of it out.
(laughter)
BRIAN: So, you had your
worming for the year.
ERIN: Temptress is being
a typical llama.
BEN: I've done a lot of horses,
they never do that.
(laughing)
ERIN: A llama's
natural defense mechanism
is to actually take
their stomach contents
and regurgitate it right at you.
BEN: A llama's spit
can travel up to 15 feet.
ERIN: There!
BRIAN: Good girl.
BEN: Now, we get to see
if she's gonna be a mama.
We're going to have to
put on the ultrasound
and get a picture here.
This is the screen that you're
going to be able to watch.
And you can just hold this.
You'll see everything
I'm seeing.
MONTE: Okay.
BEN: Alright?
MONTE: Alright.
BEN: And the most definitive
thing to see
would be really any part
of the baby,
but a heartbeat
would be the best,
because then we know
the baby's viable, it's alive,
and everything is going to be
A-OK hopefully.
BRIAN: We're hoping
for a positive result.
BEN: It's okay.
Got to move slow.
She's doing so good.
I'm not seeing
anything obvious, guys.
That's not a good sign.
Really, all I see is food
material at this point.
We could draw blood on her
if we're inconclusive,
but it's more gratifying
just to ultrasound her belly
and see if we can see that baby.
One more try.
We're going to keep looking,
because I don't like to give up.
ERIN: In llamas there's
less amniotic fluid
proportionately
surrounding that cria,
which is a baby llama.
It's not just like a lady that's
like, "Yep, it's right here."
You kind of got to go
on a little bit of a hunt
to figure out where
she's tucking this baby
if there is one there.
BEN: I think I see
something now.
When I get further down.
ERIN: That looks
like a heartbeat.
BEN: I know!
MONTE: Right there,
that's going right there?
ERIN: Yeah, mm-hmm.
BEN: Hundred percent,
she's pregnant.
That looks like a cria!
ERIN: She's a llama mama.
Woo-hoo!
BRIAN: Alright, yay!
BEN: Good.
ERIN: You guys
are having a baby.
BEN: So exciting.
She's about nine months along,
and their gestation is
11 months to 12 months,
and I've heard even 13 months.
So, that's kind of crazy
that they can hold these babies
inside them over a year.
BRIAN: This is the most
wonderful thing to happen to us.
Now we know that we're
gonna have a baby
coming in a few months,
and then we can start thinking
about building
a larger herd from that.
Good girl, mama.
You are an official mama llama.
♪ ♪
ERIN: It decided to rain today.
We're at an unusual
house call today.
Hey, it's good to see you.
MARY: Good to see you!
ERIN: Our good client, Mary,
has some concerns
about a neighborhood cat
she cares for.
She can't get near this cat
to get it to the clinic.
So, she needs our expert
cat-catching help.
MARY: It's one heck
of a house call.
ERIN: Oh, you betcha.
Well, I feel like I brought
like my team of ninjas.
MARY: We appreciate how well
Dr. Ben and Erin
take care of cats.
Cats of course are the most
important patients they see.
ERIN: What's going on
with this kitty,
or can you give me
the backstory?
MARY: Sure, Spot is one
of the neighborhood cats.
We have house cats, and we have
what we call garage cats
who will come by
for food, water,
and a warm, dry place to sleep.
I've seen him eat recently,
and he licks very carefully
at wet food
and he'll take
like a half a bite,
but he never really
closes his mouth.
BEN: It's possible
he likes canned food
because his mouth hurts.
ERIN: Scale of one to ten,
you know, one being like,
you could sleep with him
in your bed
and ten being like,
he would run.
MARY: I think we're
at about a seven or an eight.
ERIN: Okay.
BEN: Oh, he's
pretty feral, then. Wow.
MARY: I have never
touched this cat.
ERIN: Because this cat lives
on the streets
without no particular owner,
we have to assume
that it's unvaccinated.
BEN: Let's get some long sleeves
on this guy.
And I'm gonna get my gloves.
ERIN: Okay, Mary,
you got long sleeves?
MARY: I will go get some.
ERIN: It's a great idea
to wear long sleeves and gloves
to protect ourselves,
just in case this kitty's
claws come out.
If they scratch you or bite you,
kitties can transmit bacteria
through those wounds.
These are like,
very tiny gloves.
I can't get my hands.
CHASE: You want me
to get them off?
ERIN: I got giant hands.
Man hands.
CHASE: Five-year-olds, Mom.
I can't even get
my hand in there.
ERIN: I think they're Mary's.
She has like,
normal lady-sized hands.
Oh, I see his face.
BEN: He's right down there?
Oh, yeah!
MARY: He could come zipping
out of there at any moment.
ERIN: What if we put
the carrier there?
MARY: In front?
CHASE: We can just
grab his torso.
ERIN: No, he's not, he's wild.
We can't just pick him up.
BEN: He's never been touched.
I like your plan, guys.
Open up the front
of the carrier to this side.
ERIN: Yep.
BEN: Maybe we'll stick
a broom down the other side
and just kind of scoot him
from the back
and see if he goes forward.
'Cause I wanna stick this
along the backside.
ERIN: Honey, that might
spook him.
BEN: Well, I know,
but what am I going to do?
That's the whole plan.
ERIN: I think you should
just sort of gently
lay something there.
BEN: There's a lot
of ideas going on here.
Okay, let's get that carrier
right in that spot, Erin.
Let's see what happens.
CHASE: Push him.
BEN: Did he go in?
ERIN: He's looking at me.
BEN: Oh, he's looking.
He doesn't want
to really go in. Go in.
ERIN: He's headed
out the other way.
BEN: He's turned around.
MARY: There we go.
BEN: He's moving.
ERIN: He's backing up a little.
BEN: He's backing up.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
ERIN: Is he going
out the back way?
Watch out!
Honey, get him!
BEN: Mary, are you gonna try it?
MARY: Yeah, come on, Spot.
That's a good kitty.
ERIN: Got it!
BEN: Good job!
ERIN: Ta-da!
BEN: Wow!
ERIN: It's okay.
Let's cover him up here.
BEN: Okay, cover that thing up.
CHASE: How about that
athletic move on that post?
ERIN: How about the athletic
move of your mother?
(laughing)
And that's why I went to college
on a basketball scholarship.
I'm really glad that you
take care of these kitties
and love them like you do.
They're lucky to have you
as their caregiver.
BEN: I'll say.
ERIN: Mary is sort of like
our fairy cat mother.
And Spot is a patient
who's really benefiting
from her generosity.
♪ ♪
(mooing)
Hey, Val.
VAL: Hi.
ERIN: I brought you a present.
This is Mary's kitty.
Name is Spot.
I don't know if it's
a he or a she,
but it is a true feral.
The kitty is not chewing
and eating properly.
So, I think the safest thing
is to sedate it in the carrier
and then get him or her out.
♪ ♪
Val and I have done this
for a long time
where we have feral cats come in
and we just sort of
rotate the carrier
and get the kitty
so they're sitting
on a spot we can get
a syringe through
and poke quickly and easily.
By the time they realize
something's happened,
it's already all over.
So, your butt comes here, kitty.
That's what we want!
This little carrier trick helps
reduce the stress on the kitty
because she's not used to being
handled; she's a feral cat.
And it will also really help
protect Val and I.
We don't know
this cat's history,
and so I don't either of us
to get bitten.
Got it.
VAL: Good job.
ERIN: While I'm prepping
for Spot's exam,
Ben is catching up with a farmer
who has a newborn calf with
a life-threatening condition.
(laughing)
BEN: Pretty calf
in a pretty pink blanket!
AUSTIN: Yup.
I'm here because I've got a very
special calf that has a hernia.
BEN: Wow, this is a big hernia.
AUSTIN: Yeah, she was born
like this,
uh, she'll be 3 days old today.
BEN: So, normally, we've got
our strong body wall
holding all of our organs in.
She unfortunately has
a rent, or a hole,
in her abdominal wall,
and that is allowing all these
organs to just spill out.
Well, Charlie, you ever seen
a hernia that big?
CHARLIE: I've only seen like you
do two or three of them,
and they're only like
the size of a tennis ball.
This one is huge.
BEN: Yeah, this is more
like a volleyball, literally.
CHARLIE: This one's big.
BEN: This hole in her abdomen
is, it's big.
There's one edge,
and there's the other edge.
That's about three
or four inches across.
So, it's large.
Basically, the risks involved
in this surgery
are there's going to be
so much tension on my stitches
from when she starts
eating again
and really feeling good
that they could start
breaking down,
and then we have another hernia.
In people, we sometimes
get two or three tries.
In, in animals, we usually get
one try and that's it.
She's probably got
a 50/50 chance
even if everything goes well
with surgery, of making it.
♪ ♪
BEN: This is a big hernia.
Repairing this calf's hernia
is risky,
but it's her only chance
at life.
She's probably got
a 50/50 chance,
even if everything goes well
with surgery, of making it.
AUSTIN: 50% is better
than nothing, you know,
we've got to try something.
I put my whole trust in Ben.
I've had Ben on my farm
for four years now,
and I feel very confident,
because good people take care
of good people
is what I always like to say.
BEN: Charlie, let's roll her
into the other room
and then I'm going to start
getting ready for surgery.
CHARLIE: Okay.
ERIN: Okay.
Now that Spot's fallen asleep,
we can take a look
from tip to tail
and see if we can figure out
why she's not eating.
I'm just going to look here
first at these teeth.
Ooh, can you smell that?
VAL: Mm-hm.
ERIN: Ugh.
Uh, it smells like infection.
Yucky, kitty.
She's got some bad teeth.
Darn it.
You know, we've got some tartar,
some gingivitis.
We'll just clean them
and see what we have
underneath that tartar
and what needs to come out.
VAL: Okay.
ERIN: While preparing Spot
for surgery,
I'm noticing much more
than rotten teeth.
Ooh, so she has
these ulcerations
on the back of her tongue
and her throat, you see that?
VAL: Oh, yeah.
ERIN: What is,
what is causing that?
The ulcers on the back
of Spot's tongue
are really indicating that
there's an infection present.
If left untreated,
this infection
could really make it tough for
Spot to chew and swallow food.
We definitely need to run
blood work to find out more.
Okay, blood, blood, blood.
(whirring)
We need to move quickly while
Spot's under anesthesia,
so Val's gonna get
Spot's dental started,
and I'm gonna take
her blood work
and see if we have
any other conditions
flying under the radar.
VAL: Okay, Erin, so,
when I was cleaning here,
we got a lower molar here,
pretty painful.
ERIN: Ooh. Oh, yep.
There's a little
resorptive lesion.
It's hitting that nerve
and making her jaw
kind of jump around a little.
So, that's kind of back where
that lesion was on her tongue,
those sores.
So, I'm wondering if she's
really having an issue,
that that tooth is causing
that infection
that's irritating her tongue.
So, let's get that tooth
out of here.
We'll get her
an injectable antibiotic
and some pain medicines.
Great news, her blood work
is totally normal.
So, she's a nice, healthy cat as
far as her organs are concerned.
If you can get ready,
I'll cut that tooth
and get it pulled.
Well, I'm just going
to cut the gum away.
(whirring)
Okay, perfect.
I got the tooth split,
and here we go.
There's that back root.
This decayed tooth and
the infection on her tongue
are definitely the cause
of Spot's issues.
It's a great thing
that Mary noticed
that Spot was eating funny,
because this infection could
have taken over in her mouth,
and then who knows
what might have happened.
Alright, Miss Spotty.
Now Spot can return to
a pain-free life on the prowl.
Okay. I'll call Mary.
A good deed was done.
(moo)
BEN: I'm gonna give her
her pre-meds.
Okay, she's definitely out now.
We're gonna go
right into surgery.
♪ ♪
Well, we've got the calf
all cleaned, ready for surgery.
Erin, luckily, is
going to help me.
CHARLIE: Look at that, Mom.
Look at it when she breathes.
ERIN: I know, it goes
urpy out the hole.
BEN: This is actually
one of the biggest hernias
I've ever repaired.
If we did nothing,
this calf would probably
lay around for 2 or 3 months
and some of the intestines
would probably get stuck
down in the hernia,
and then the calf can't poop
anymore and she would die.
♪ ♪
Okay, guys.
Here goes my incision.
This is actually an elliptical
incision around the hernia.
CHARLIE: Is that tougher than
making a normal straight line?
BEN: It is.
You kinda got to be an artiste.
It gets rid of some
of the extra tissue right away,
and it gives me a baseline
of exactly where to be
for the repair.
Okay, so, I've got
my elliptical incision here,
and now I'm going to cut
that skin all out.
ERIN: Your hole is going
to get scary big.
BEN: I know it is.
♪ ♪
ERIN: That's an enormous hole.
Not the one you're making,
the one in her gut. You know?
BEN: Did you feel it?
ERIN: Yeah.
BEN: Mm-hm.
ERIN: Like, you could park
a truck in that thing.
BEN: Too big.
Wow, this is all those
intestines right here.
CHARLIE: That's a lot.
BEN: Mm-hm.
She's pushing up on my hole
quite a bit.
CHARLIE: Does it make it tougher
when those intestines
are popping up?
BEN: It does.
So, what I got here is
muscle way over here...
ERIN: Yeah.
BEN: ...and way over here.
Those edges are very far apart
from each other.
What I need to do is, Erin,
have you glove in and hold that.
ERIN: Okay.
BEN: So, I'm going
to clamp these together.
This is going to make or break
the whole surgery right here.
BEN: This is going
to make or break
the whole surgery right here.
Erin and I are in surgery
with a three-day-old calf.
This poor baby has the largest
hernia I've ever worked on.
We got to get from here
over to there.
ERIN: Mm-hm.
BEN: And we got to freshen it.
What I mean by freshen the edges
is I'm going to actually
cut along them
and get some live cells
bleeding,
and when we sew that together,
that has a chance of actually
being one piece of tissue again.
There we're going.
I say we sew that first half.
Such a big hole.
Right in the middle
where I put the towel clamp
to hold the two pieces
of body wall together,
that's ground zero.
Erin and I decided let's do
half of it first,
and then we work from the back
up to the towel clamps
so we met in the middle,
and if one of those would break,
we still have half of it
that's holding.
Okay, so, we've got
the top half sewn together.
Now we got to work
on the bottom half.
BEN: Okay.
That was a good bite.
One more, okay?
You at first have to close
the body wall,
then you close
the subcutaneous layer,
and then you close
the skin after that.
A three-layer closure has
more strength and stability
than if you were just to close
everything all in one big swoop.
That looks pretty good.
Thanks for your help.
ERIN: You betcha, baby.
BEN: I've just fixed
the biggest hernia
I've ever fixed
in my whole career.
But just because
this surgery went well
doesn't mean this calf's
in the clear.
Tomorrow she'll go home
and recover on the farm.
Austin will have to
keep her clean and dry
and make sure she doesn't
eat too much
and stretch out that new belly.
♪ ♪
ERIN: Hey, honey.
BEN: Hi.
ERIN: I need to talk
with you on something.
You know what I'm really
kind of missing is a dog.
BEN: A dog?
ERIN: I was thinking maybe
it would be a good thing
for the boys maybe
to have some chores.
This might even be for us.
They're going to be
out of the house soon, so...
BEN: Yeah, we might need
a companion
in a few years ourselves.
ERIN: I'll have to
just talk to you.
BEN: We don't want that.
ERIN: You on board?
BEN: I am.
Erin is often asking
about new animals.
We always are talking
about getting a new pet,
but it's tough to do
because we work a lot,
but I don't really think there's
any stopping her this time.
What do you got in mind?
ERIN: Well...
BEN: Oh, you've been
searching already.
This is a real thing.
ERIN: Yeah. You know me.
I like to online shop,
but Chase and I
kind of were looking,
and I found one named Bud.
BEN: Bud looks nice.
ERIN: He just came
available for adoption.
This could be the one.
♪ ♪
Come on, Spot.
Mom's here.
Spot has recovered wonderfully
after her surgery yesterday.
Hi, Mary.
MARY: Hello.
ERIN: She's eating well,
she's gone to the bathroom,
and she is ready to return
to the great outdoors.
Your cat radar was on fire,
and she did have a tooth
with a resorptive lesion.
That very sensitive portion
of the tooth was exposed.
So we did remove that molar.
MARY: Good.
ERIN: She did have
some associated sores
on the back of her tongue
and on her throat
that were sort of infection.
Treated her with
a two-week antibiotic
so you don't have to give her
anything, which is great.
MARY: Great.
ERIN: She also has
pain medication on board
that'll last another 12 hours.
She is very feral,
but she's very kind.
You can release her
into the garage,
and if you can keep her in there
for another day or two
just to make sure
she's eating, drinking.
MARY: Sure.
I'm sure she's just
scared and tired.
She had one of the worst days
of her life yesterday,
but it's also one of
the best days of her life.
ERIN: Exactly.
I really do believe,
left untreated,
she would have deteriorated.
I'm grateful that you
took care of her.
She's grateful.
MARY: I'm grateful you all were
available to come help get her.
ERIN: Well, it just
worked out perfect.
MARY: I worried
about her last night,
and it's great to have her back
and headed back home.
ERIN: Please keep us posted
on how she does.
MARY: I will.
ERIN: Okay, thank you.
MARY: Thanks, see ya!
♪ ♪
ERIN: We just got a call
from a client
who has a Jack Russell terrier
that had two seizures.
I told them immediately to load
the dog up and let's get here.
The dog may walk in normal,
or he could come in
completely flat.
(doorbell)
And I think I actually
just heard them come in.
ERIN: Ooh, he's having
a seizure right now.
VAL: Watch your fingers.
Watch your fingers.
ERIN: Okay. How long
have you had him?
LOGAN: It's been
a couple months.
ERIN: And no seizures before?
LOGAN: No. Never seen him
do this before.
ERIN: This dog is
a recent adoption
and its medical history
is a complete unknown.
I'm going to have Val
grab anti-seizure meds
while I run blood work.
We've got to start
some diagnostics
to see what's going on
and what's causing this.
This is not a good situation.
Alright, Val, you got him?
Okay, it's alright, buddy.
ERIN: Val, you got him?
VAL: Okay.
ERIN: I'm going to get blood
running first, okay.
It's alright, buddy.
We're looking for clues
as to why Rascal is seizing.
The blood work
will give us information
on his organ function
and electrolytes,
and the other diagnostics will
hopefully point us to a cause.
Val, let's go ahead and
get an IV catheter in him.
You're alright.
You're alright, Rascal.
While we wait to get
the blood work results,
we're gonna get a catheter in
for supportive care.
Katelyn.
Hold on to his butt.
VAL: Rascal.
ERIN: Hey, hey, hey, Rascal.
This is an important step,
Rascal.
Please be good and hold still.
It's okay.
LOGAN: We adopted him
two months ago.
We haven't seen
any seizure activity
in the months we've had him,
so what caused it?
How do we make this little,
happy little dog,
be a happy little dog?
ERIN: Have you done
any fertilizer,
anything for the crops,
anything at all like that?
LOGAN: The neighbor just
did the fungicide, but...
ERIN: The neighbor
did do a fungicide?
LOGAN: Yeah.
ERIN: Okay.
VAL: Dad's right there.
Stay here.
ERIN: I'm thinking because
he's never had seizures before,
and he's had three this morning,
that there is potentially
some sort of ingestion.
He's a farm dog,
so there are a zillion things
that are around a farm that
can be poisonous to dogs.
Please all work.
LOGAN: I just knew
something was wrong.
What's gonna happen
to this little dog?
ERIN: Everything is completely
normal on his blood work.
His glucose is okay,
his liver enzymes are okay,
his kidneys are okay.
I feel like ingestion
or toxicity
is a little lower down the list.
I think I'd like
to just check x-rays
since we've never had a seizure.
There's no other great answer
that I have.
(dog panting)
He's always been able
to see you, right?
LOGAN: Yeah.
ERIN: He's never had
any issues with that?
As I'm taking a look at Rascal,
I'm noticing that something
is up with his vision.
That's abnormal.
He's not visual right now.
There could be
something going on.
ERIN: Certainly that, but it
could also be mass, brain tumor,
I mean, there's a lot of things
we may not see,
anything that could suddenly
cause that issue.
Okay, well, let's go
get this taken.
Lori, could you give Ben a call?
LORI: Yeah!
ERIN: Thank you.
Ben's our eye expert.
So, while I'm taking
these x-rays,
I'm gonna have him
come take a look
and make sure that I'm not
missing something.
♪ ♪
Logan, x-rays, really
nothing abnormal there.
LOGAN: Okay.
ERIN: Yeah, empty tummy,
so, good things.
Lots of good things.
I don't see a large tumor.
We'll just get him settled down
and have Ben look at his eyes.
He's not painful.
His x-rays look fine.
His cervical vertebrae
look fine.
With the vision loss is weird,
that doesn't really
go with ingestion.
And he's not vomiting,
you know, most of these things
make them sick to their belly.
He's not giving us
very many hints
as to what's going on here.
♪ ♪
BEN: Everything
looks great there.
Doesn't look abnormal at all.
ERIN: No hemorrhage
in the eye? Yeah.
BEN: Let's say we have no vision
from pressure
on the optic nerves.
ERIN: Yeah.
BEN: I mean,
that's very possible.
ERIN: Yeah.
BEN: We need some non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories
to counteract that.
ERIN: These meds will help
reduce the swelling
that may be affecting
his vision.
But the good news is, we've
ruled out everything else
that we can, so this
has got to be epilepsy.
I think we have to treat him
like an epileptic.
We need to control
these seizures.
It's supportive care,
and wait and see.
BEN: Yeah.
ERIN: Okay, let's start
with that.
Epilepsy is a condition
you diagnose by exclusion,
and I feel very confident
that we've ruled out
all these other culprits that
could be causing these seizures.
So we're gonna start Rascal
on anti-seizure meds,
and we're gonna have our intern,
Katelyn, sit with him
this afternoon and monitor
for any breakthrough seizures.
Katelyn, I think we put him
in that kennel
and he's gonna really get upset.
So, whatever chair
you want to sit in,
you want
intern-plus-plus duties,
is to sit out and
hang out with him,
and you're on seizure watch.
ERIN: Yell.
♪ ♪
BEN: Chase and I are heading out
to Austin's farm
for a checkup on his calf.
The hernia surgery
went really well.
Hey, Austin.
AUSTIN: How's it going?
BEN: But we truly won't know
until we can get a good look
at that belly,
make sure the sutures
are holding tight,
and everything is where it
should be, and that's inside.
Ooh, she's kicking today.
We got a little different calf
here today, don't we Austin?
AUSTIN: A little bit,
from the last time you saw her.
BEN: Feels good.
Okay, I'm gonna carefully
not trying to get kicked here.
AUSTIN: Put her on her side?
BEN: Okay, ready?
Oh. There we go.
Chase, why don't you
come around here?
(laughing)
Help me hold legs.
Good.
Alright, you know, really we've
got some beautiful healing
that's happened here.
We got just a little bit
of a area
where the sutures are reacting,
and that's okay, you know.
These two spots here, that's
where our big knots were.
This is just scar tissue.
This incision went from here
all the way down to here,
and it looks great.
I mean, we just pulled her
out of the yard.
You know, it's a rainy day.
There's a little bit
of mud on it,
but it's healing up
and it's closing.
For what she's gone through and
with the big surgery she's had,
all of her guts and intestine
and all those
abdominal contents,
they have no chance
of coming out anymore,
and that's
the important thing here.
This is a win, you know.
AUSTIN: Yeah.
BEN: We did
a life-saving surgery,
and, um, now she can go
live out her life.
AUSTIN: It wasn't
very good odds,
but I'm glad we beat the odds.
So, I'm glad to save her life.
Thank you.
BEN: Thank you.
♪ ♪
Good job, Charlie.
CHARLIE: Thanks, Dad.
I'm actually working.
BEN: Lot of book work
when you're a vet,
you know that, right?
CHARLIE:
Seems like you're always
doing something over there.
The Thoenes are here.
BEN: I wonder what they got.
The Thoene boys are kind of like
the Tom Sawyers and Huck Finns
of this town.
Ty, Trev, and Myles.
Anytime they show up,
you just know they've got
themselves into something.
(laughs)
Charlie, you got to see this.
CHARLIE: Oh, boy.
BEN: What do you got in there?
Let's take a look.
A band of local brothers
has come into the clinic,
and what they've brought in
is wild, literally.
(laughs)
CHARLIE: A little baby raccoon.
MYLES: We found the raccoon
in our shop on our farm.
It's a wild animal and we didn't
really know what to do with it.
BEN: They're one
of those species
where we kind of think
they're nuisances
or these little guys that
tear apart our garbage cans,
but it's helpless,
it's an orphan.
We need to take care
of this little raccoon.
A raccoon is a wild animal.
They can carry this parasite
that is not very good
for people to get.
So, we want to all put on gloves
and then we'll take
a look here, okay.
The roundworm is shed
by raccoons,
just kind of like dogs and cats,
but their specific roundworm,
if it gets into a human,
can migrate through your body
and go into really weird places,
like your eyes or your brain.
Set it right there.
It's definitely something you
don't want to mess around with.
It can be fatal.
Oh, my goodness.
Hi.
Alright, let's see
what we're dealing with.
A boy or a girl.
Okay.
Looks to be a little girl
raccoon, guys.
Any names so far yet?
MYLES: Ricki.
BEN: Ricki.
Okay, Ricki can work for a girl.
Oh, my goodness.
She's trying to nurse
anything she can.
She's hungry.
Let's mix up some
kitten milk replacer,
and we'll definitely want
to get her dewormed, too.
Every veterinarian in my opinion
needs to take care
of any of these animals
that come in our door.
How's that bottle
coming, Charlie?
CHARLIE: Good, I'm almost done.
BEN: We get caught up a lot
in trying to make our business
make money
and do things that pay
our bills and feed us.
Wildlife doesn't do that,
but it is an obligation
in our profession.
This is the dewormer.
Oh...
MYLES: It's not milk.
CHARLIE: It's not milk.
BEN: Alright.
That was easy, wasn't it, guys?
Let's see if this little baby
will nurse.
Oh, she's figuring it out.
CHARLIE: Wow, look
at how hungry it is.
BEN: Ty, I think you
can handle this.
You want to hold her?
TY: Yeah.
BEN: I don't think she's
giving that up for nothing.
Ty, you should maybe think
about going into this field.
You kind of know how to do that.
I think the smartest thing to do
with a wild animal like this
would be to have somebody
who's really proficient
in taking care of them do that.
CHARLIE: I don't know,
I kind of want to keep it.
BEN: You must have more of your
mom in you than what I thought,
and, uh, the answer is no.
CHARLIE: Dang it.
BEN: The Thoene boys are going
to take this little raccoon
to the animal refuge center,
and they should be able to take
care of this little raccoon
until it's released into
the wild, which is great.
Why not try to save
a life, right?
It's awesome.
♪ ♪
ERIN: Hi.
Alright. It's okay.
I know.
Your mommy's here.
Our patient Rascal came into
the clinic in critical condition
after a string of seizures.
After 24 hours of observation
and treatment,
we're sending him home.
But he's not
out of the woods yet.
STACY: Hey, boo-boo.
Hi, buddy.
(kiss)
ERIN: There's been no more
seizures since he's been here.
All the blood work came back
completely normal.
I think he's
a little more visual.
Oh, he's definitely,
that's better.
Are you yawning?
There's really no other
reason we can find.
You know, that leaves
basically epilepsy.
I want you to keep him
on epileptic meds
to treat his seizures.
A brain tumor is sort of
worse-case scenario.
So, we would treat
with epileptic drugs
and certainly if that
did not resolve it,
then you know, have other
conversations, you know...
STACY: Stay on top of it.
ERIN: Stay on top of that.
I'm hopeful,
but I definitely want to
check up on him in a few weeks
to see how the treatment
is working.
STACY: He's definitely loved.
So, Logan has a birthday picture
to show you.
ERIN: Oh, when was
your birthday?
STACY: Not ours, his.
ERIN: Oh, look at him in his
sumo outfit for his birthday.
(laughing)
Well, call me if you need me.
STACY: Okay.
ERIN: Bye, buddy.
Okay, alright.
STACY: Thank you.
ERIN: Thank you.
STACY: Okay, ready?
♪ ♪
ERIN: Hi, how are you guys?
OLIVIA: Good.
ERIN: Oh, my goodness.
Those are the prettiest
bunnies ever.
Um, you guys just want
to go into two?
OLIVIA: Okay.
ERIN: Olivia and her mom
are here with a ton of bunnies
that she raised
for her 4-H project.
BEN: So, this is a health paper
for your fair, right?
OLIVIA: Yes. I've been a 4-H
member for about four years.
I brought my bunnies
to the clinic here today
to get their normal health
checkup for the fair.
Otherwise they can't be
a member of the fair,
and that's what I do.
ERIN: It's bunny time!
4-H programs help teach kids
about leadership
and commitment
to their communities.
OLIVIA: This is Jack,
a Holland lop.
BEN: Because of his lop ears.
OLIVIA: Yes.
ERIN: We're just checking to
make sure none of these animals
have any signs
of infectious disease.
Sounds great.
We don't want anybody bringing
something to the fair
that they're going to share
with their neighbor.
BEN: What breed is this one?
OLIVIA: A lion head.
ERIN: Cutest thing I've ever
seen in my life.
Oh, my gosh, honey.
We have to get one
that's house-trained.
BEN: That's great.
ERIN: Lungs sound great.
The lion head is
a breed of rabbit
that has a long mane of fur
around its head.
Their origin is unknown,
but who cares,
they are the cutest things
on the planet.
BEN: Just a tiny
little bunny here.
Nose looks good.
Look, he matches my shirt.
ERIN: I know.
Honey, there's more bunnies.
BEN: I'm good.
(laughter)
OLIVIA: This is a Charlie
because he has a half mustache.
ERIN: Are you a Charlie?
The half mustache
comes from a broken gene
that's inherited
from each parent,
making these rabbits look
like Charlie Chaplain.
OLIVIA: Oh, that's Willie.
BEN: Good nose.
Eyes look clear.
OLIVIA: This is Buttercup.
She's a red-eyed white.
BEN: How's that butt look?
ERIN: That butt looks great.
BEN: They've all got their
normal, hard rabbit poops?
Good catch, Olivia.
ERIN: Good catch. Sorry.
OLIVIA: You're okay.
ERIN: I am totally impressed.
You really know your animals
and they are clean,
they're well taken care of.
OLIVIA: I love raising them
'cause it kinda gives me
like a feeling of peace.
I spend so much time with them,
it's just kind of like
my favorite thing to do now.
ERIN: Good luck, my dear.
OLIVIA: Nice meeting you.
ERIN: Totally. Same here,
and thank you for bringing them
down today and sharing them.
♪ ♪
BEN: We got a late call
from a dairy farmer.
One of his milk cows has been
sick for a day or two
and hasn't improved.
He's starting to get worried,
and rightfully so.
When a cow doesn't eat, it could
mean a number of serious issues.
So, Erin and I are heading
to the farm with the boys
to check her out.
ERIN: Got it, Chase?
Oh, gosh.
Hey, Mark!
BEN: Quite a storm we're having.
MARK: Yeah, yeah.
BEN: Can you lead us
to where she's at?
MARK: Yep.
♪ ♪
BEN: One thing I just noticed
is she's kind of straining.
MARK: Okay.
BEN: You know, not much
fecal material's coming out.
So, that means something
may be twisted internally.
I'll take a quick listen here
and see what we got.
(flicking)
Chase, can I show you this?
I just want you to listen to it.
I'm going to ping real hard
against her abdomen.
What's it sound like?
CHASE: Like a basketball.
BEN: It's full of air.
So, it sounds like
a displaced abomasum.
A displaced abomasum,
or more commonly called a DA,
is the fourth stomach of a cow
that is shifted out of place.
It always occurs from them
not eating for a day or two,
and then gas building up
in the stomach
where there's no food
holding it down into place.
Eventually they do die.
The left DA,
which is what she has,
is fixable with a roll, okay?
MARK: Okay.
BEN: You basically roll them
on their back,
get the abomasum
right into place.
So, we can fix her without going
into her abdomen
and actually having surgery...
MARK: Okay.
BEN: ...which is
a good thing for her.
Especially, uh,
on a night like this.
I'm glad I brought everybody
along in the family
because now we have
lots of hands on deck,
because we need to go
cow tipping.
MARK: Okay.
BEN: Okay.
(laughter)
We'll lightly sedate her
so she doesn't fight us
during the roll.
Okay, and I'm going to give it.
She's going to start going
to sleep pretty quick.
So, go ahead and let her loose.
We're going to pull her down.
She has to roll the correct way.
Right side, legs over.
So that way the stomach
comes up to the top
in the right direction.
As far as difficulty, this is
probably a nine out of ten.
I know a lot of veterinarians
that don't like to do
this procedure
because it takes practice,
and luckily, I had a father
who taught me how to do it.
This is not something
I learned in vet school,
I promise you that.
I learned it
from John Schroeder.
Okay, here we go.
I'm gonna pull.
Yeah, she's really bracing.
CHARLIE: Come on, girl.
BEN: We're gonna pull her down.
She has to roll the correct way.
Okay, here we go.
I'm going to pull.
This dairy cow has
a displaced abomasum.
That's basically
a twisted stomach.
She's really bracing.
We're rolling her on her back
to get this stomach
back into place,
but this 1,500-pound cow
has got ideas of her own.
CHARLIE: Come on, girl.
ERIN: Oh, she's going.
There we go.
BEN: Yes.
ERIN: Oh, roll your feet
that way.
BEN: Okay, hold this
tight, Mark.
We're going to
push her over, ready?
Good, just like that.
BEN: 1,500 to
2,000-pound animal,
they aren't the best breathers
when they're on their feet,
let alone on their back.
And so, you have to do
this procedure
quickly and efficiently.
It's dangerous for them.
Now, go over to that other
next post and give it one wrap.
I'm going to pull
and you're going to pull.
I'm going to pull,
you're going to pull.
Pull. One more time.
One more time.
Alright, that abomasum
should be back in place.
So, we're going to give her
a lot of sugar right now.
Alright, I can still see a vein.
That's good.
(cow bellowing)
So, we want her to get
back on her feet soon,
and the sugar should
really do that.
All done with the fluids.
ERIN: She's waking up, honey.
BEN: Oh, yeah, she's
about ready, isn't she?
ERIN: Time to wakey, wakey.
CHARLIE: Sugar's hitting.
BEN: Come on, girl.
There you go.
Get up, girl.
CHARLIE: You know
what your back feet are.
BEN: Now, the next thing is,
she needs help herself.
She needs to go right back
to eating and drinking
and put a lot of weight
in that abomasum,
and that will hold it
into place.
Alright, I love that she's
eating and drinking.
ERIN: Well, I'd say
that that's a good sign.
BEN: I'm glad
we came out tonight.
I know it's wet and cold,
but morning could have been
worse off.
MARK: Yeah, thanks
for coming tonight.
BEN: You bet.
♪ ♪
ERIN: So we're on our way
to go see Rascal,
who is the little doggy that
we diagnosed with epilepsy,
and just check in and
see how his meds are going.
Making sure that he's responding
and that he's comfortable,
and that mom and dad
are comfortable
with all the recommendations
that we've given.
It is windy.
(knocks)
ERIN: Hi!
STACY: Hello!
ERIN: How are you?
Man, he looks good!
STACY: I know!
ERIN: How's he doing?
STACY: Good! So far.
ERIN: So far, so good?
Eating, drinking? Fine?
STACY: Perfect.
ERIN: And how about his vision?
STACY: Um, so far, so good.
ERIN: And is he playing
and being a happy dog?
LOGAN: He's getting to be,
more and more.
STACY: More social. He doesn't
chase the cats as much.
ERIN: They did tip me
extra for that.
STACY: Perfect!
ERIN: You know,
it's really positive
we haven't seen
any more seizures.
STACY: Yes, absolutely.
ERIN: That is something
I'll never forget watching him
go through, and hopefully we
don't ever have to see it again.
Well, I am so glad
I got to swing by today.
I mean, he's just a different
dog, he's alert, he's bright.
And he just looks,
he just looks happy.
You know my number,
you can call me anytime.
STACY: Thank you!
ERIN: Yes.
ERIN: Bye, Rascal.
♪ ♪
Alright, Chase, I think
this is the day.
Hey, Kerry.
KERRY: Hi, guys!
ERIN: We are in
Yankton, South Dakota,
at the Heartland Humane Society
looking for some dogs
that are available for adoption.
You have a little
whippet-type dog.
KERRY: It was adopted
this morning.
ERIN: Oh, no! Well, darn it.
KERRY: I got black cats and
ten other dogs back there.
ERIN: What do you got for dogs?
KERRY: Yeah, let's go look.
(barking)
ERIN: Alright, so who do
you have in here?
KERRY: We've got, Nellie's new,
Great Pyrenees.
ERIN: Hi, Nellie.
KERRY: Really sweet, sweet girl.
ERIN: Oh, she is sweet.
She's a little bit big.
KERRY: Little big for you,
absolutely.
Both Rigs and Winnie
came in in the last week.
ERIN: Hi, guys.
KERRY: She's probably
still growing, though.
She's only seven months old.
ERIN: I'm not sure I could carry
you up the stairs when you age.
'Cause how old are you?
Two years.
Do you have any little dogs?
KERRY: Yeah, the only two
I have are paired.
They've got to go together.
ERIN: Well, this is
the right size.
KERRY: This is Happy
and Skittles.
ERIN: Hi, guys.
KERRY: Their owner
just got too old.
So, they're looking for a fresh
family to finish life out with.
They definitely are
happy to see you.
ERIN: There's just something
there I really like
about these two little dogs.
They're kind of like
"The Odd Couple."
ERIN: Do you like them?
CHASE: Yeah.
ERIN: They're pretty cute.
But it's two. It's two.
Oh, my gosh, I'm going
to end up a single woman
with two kids I have to care of
and two dogs.
KERRY: You want
to get them out?
ERIN: Yeah. Let's see.
Let's get them out.
Hi, guys.
Hi, oh, well,
aren't you convincing?
Chase and I love
these little dogs.
Happy is awesome.
Skittles is so snuggly
and cuddly.
But it's still two dogs.
So, this isn't a decision
to take lightly.
Oh, he's snuggling you.
(mooing)
♪ ♪
(horn honks)
CHARLIE: It's Mom.
BEN: Let's go see what she got.
ERIN: Here, you stay here.
BEN: Hey, hon, how'd it go?
ERIN: Well, we got a dog.
BEN: Aw, he's awesome,
look at you, buddy.
ERIN: This is Skittles.
CHARLIE: Hey, Skittles!
BEN: Skittles?
ERIN: And Happy.
BEN: What? Two dogs?
ERIN: Two dogs!
BEN: Man, I had no idea.
I was thinking she might
just go and look.
We talked about one dog,
but two dogs?
What happened here?
ERIN: These guys were
a bonded pair,
and they are 8 and 12.
BEN: Oh, wow, I like it.
So, they're probably
housebroken.
ERIN: They're supposed
to be housebroken.
They've been around
kitties, kids,
and you had to take them both.
We went up there to get Bud,
and he had been adopted,
so Kerry just kind of
showed us what she had,
and we fell in love.
How can you not love them?
BEN: Look at him.
ERIN: Skittles does tricks.
CHARLIE: Skittles,
you can do tricks?
BEN: What tricks
does he do, hon?
ERIN: Do sit.
Speak.
(ruff)
Beg.
Oh, there.
Doesn't he, he's so cool.
BEN: Oh, my gosh.
CHARLIE: Good dog.
BEN: I'm actually
really excited.
ERIN: Yeah, aren't they cute?
BEN: Hey, we have two kids,
we might as well have two dogs.
ERIN: Yeah.
BEN: All kidding aside,
I think Skittles and Happy
are going to be a wonderful
addition to our family.
ERIN: You like, guys?
CHARLIE: Yeah.
ERIN: Did Chase and I do good?
CHARLIE: Yes.
ERIN: I am so happy that we have
these two new additions.
A lot of times older dogs
get overlooked
in a shelter situation because
they aren't playful puppies,
but they need love
and they need homes, too.
Job number one, potty walks.
BEN: Okay.
Let's go walk 'em, Chuck.
ERIN: Alright.
BEN: Come on, Happy.
CHARLIE: Come on, Skittles.
ERIN: Good job, baby. We did it.
Captioned by
Side Door Media Services